what were your expectations for
netflix's
i guess first original feature series
was there any concern that it would be
too big of a risk at the time or were
you already seeing particular signs that
suggested it was going to turn into this
epic empire
yeah i really didn't see epic empire
in its future i knew it was going to be
a
specialized style called david fincher
and i just
he's one of my favorites as a director
and just watching him
work after seeing all of his movies for
so many years and then getting to
witness him on on set um
i learned so much from him a and i just
trusted him he said trust me
this is going to be the new future it's
called streaming
and we are basically the founders of it
with netflix
um and not only
is this a show where you're not going to
know from year to year
if you're going to be picked up again
we have the freedom to
let claire underwood evolve we don't
even know where she's going to end up
yet so they didn't have this arc planned
because we didn't know if we were going
to be on for one year two years or six
um and working with him
and and the showrunner at the time to to
start to create who do we want claire to
become
and i remember saying well ultimately by
the end she's got to become the first
female president oh we got it i mean
this is the platform to do it let's do
it
how about just in terms of your personal
growth behind the lens because you had a
really interesting path with that series
uh directing your first episode i think
in season two becoming an executive
producer a little later on
how did it influence your work in front
of the lens when those
behind the lens components started to
kick in when you're
acting indirect you have to have an
incredible team there's no possible way
to do it without your team being your
backbone
and in essence i had three female
producers
on this movie as an example um they were
on set every day all day every minute
they were there
watching playback so that if i couldn't
get back to watch
a take that i had done i could just lean
out of the cabin and be like was that
good was it terrible
and they'd be like no you need to tell
the camera to move around
closer to your face definitely do
another take and
this time you know run out in the rain
things like that
so i had co-directors um
and we had discussed the movie the tone
who edie was who edie and miguel were to
each other
we had discussed it for a year prior to
starting
uh principal photography so everyone was
on the same page
of what we wanted this movie land to
feel like
and that atmosphere is hands down one of
the most effective
elements of the movie amongst many
others i did want to stick with house of
cards for one more question because you
just emphasize the value of
of a team effort and the folks around
you but you were also an invaluable
leader on that set when season six came
around so i was wondering was there any
apprehension into stepping into that
kind of role
or did you kind of just immediately know
that you had to do it where it felt like
a very natural progression for you
yeah the latter you just naturally knew
that that's
what needed to be done um you know they
netflix uh and our other investors
they needed to let the storm settle
because the climate was so hot right at
the time
and everybody was kind of
discombobulated like what is going on
what is that going to do
to shooting
these shows and um
and we all just said why don't we just
take a breather
we shut down the show for over a month i
think we collectively just decided we
can't do this to the fans
and equally importantly i didn't want
all of those
employees that had worked on house of
cards that's our family
they have families to take care of and
college
educations to pay for and kids to feed
and you know like anybody losing a job
i just like no we can't do that to them
so netflix and mrc agreed
let's resume and we will go out with a
[Applause]
bang
you